hey guys this is the founder figure this
is david griffin your resident comic
book and video game guru and this is our
review of the comedy this is the end the
post-apocalypse the POC elliptic is
nothing i post apocalyptic yeah it's
like during during during common movie
that has like a bunch of people and it
all playing themselves and you get Seth
Rogen Jay Baruchel Rihanna yayan James
Franco's I'm sorry Danny McBride Craig
Robinson Jonah Hill like there's so many
some surprise cameos dual coil yeah so
yeah overall it's a funny movie yeah
funny movie it's a bit long you know for
what it is I felt during the wheels like
okay this needs to like start wrapping
up here trying to keep trying to be like
it had like a walking dead kind of scope
movie you know like a story like that
but it's a comedy because it's silly
it's like they probably could a trim
maybe fish yeah I think because it was
based on a short film that the Jay and
Seth had done before I think they even
had that online and they turned into
full-on movie so it kind of felt that
way where where they were taking
something that had you know a little bit
of story and they kind of stretched it
out right I mean it was funny throughout
yeah for sure but there's definitely
like lulz and right in where they're
like trying to tell a story or simply an
homage something like their other you
know some of the older movie hangs like
that and it's like you know me sometimes
they could have cut a few things but it
was still really fun at don't yes it's
it's kind of like a really long funny
SNL sketch or something fan and a lot of
like meta stuff where it's like
self-referential playing on on the
perceptions of actors or or even just
that themselves and stuff like that the
one thing I would say is the humor is a
lot of like dick and fart jokes you know
it like if you don't like that kind of
dick and fart joke you're you're not
gonna like it a lot of pop cultural
references sure actors are just in
general and stuff like that so I think
if you don't like that or if you don't
aren't kind of like up to date on that
stuff you you might not appreciate as
much especially like seeing movies that
these guys have been in before it was
like some of this stuff with Jay and
Seth might have been somewhat tied to
real life yeah it seems like
because I mean jae hee hee its role so
he's working he's how to train your
dragon I got a sequel come he does work
but he's not as popular as Seth Rogen is
it says kind of blew up so you wonder if
that was actually kind of a true story
if I accept blew up in their friendship
may have been strained at some time in
the past or yeah and they had men on
undeclared which was like Judd Apatow
series after freaks and geeks which he
did with a Paul fig that that that's
where Franco and Seth Rogen and Jason
Segel all met like it's basically like
this big a patel paul feig yeah like
ensemble cast all alumni's of those two
shows Billy and you know and then you
got Jonah Hill and Danny McBride up
sears had a bunch of stuff with Rogen
it's like the whole crew they've worked
with super bad you know like no homebrew
so it's it's a good group of people I
mean everybody's in it but yeah just if
anything is only weakness to it I think
it could have been a little long but
yeah it is a long for what the story in
and and yeah I think I think if you know
the back has proved the actors and
whatnot and where they come from it is a
little bit funnier they're like little
things here and there may be kind of
inside jokes but right but overall yeah
I thought it was funny it was
entertaining um what would you give it i
think i give it a i give it a be okay i
really enjoyed it you know i think is a
little bit long I don't know if I'd want
to like likes movies like superbad some
other ones those guys I'm in the past
where I've come back and watched again
and again I don't know if I'd I might
see this one more time I would watch it
again and again and again but it was so
good i give it a be i definitely
recommend seeing it yeah i think i'll
give it a B+ i thought you know for
comedies like the story's not really the
thing you know it's just about how much
you laugh and you know everyone in the
theater laughed a lot so I think it did
its job um yeah I don't think I think
the last comment i laughed that much was
probably 21 Jump Street yeah that was
great when one job did I love it has the
kind of similar humor that 21 distri had
like it more of a story to it but the
same kind of humor right is do that but
I think a lot of it it's like must have
been improv do you know they must be
like oh yeah so much that if you know
you gonna do this in this but like a lot
of the lines I'm sure we're
were impressive I was hoping at the end
of the movie there's no extra credit
sure I think so you don't worry about
staying I wish there would have been
maybe like some you know they do like
the outtakes using a lot of comedies I
wish you would had some of that but we
don't get to see ya alright guys so make
sure you subscribe to our channel that's
a think Carol pro for more of our
reviews and other videos you also can
follow us on twitter minds at Finn Kira
I'm at Griffin de and we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans